for many Guantanamo Bay conjures images
of detainees and orange jumpsuits and
concertina wire but the Guantanamo Bay
that photographer Debbie Cornwall is
documented and her project called Gitmo
at home get bought play speaks to the
many contradictions of the slice of
America and Cuba
Oh
Cornwall visited the secretive military
base after nine months of negotiations
with the Navy / images were subjected to
a daily operational security review as
she was not allowed to photograph
anyone's face soldier or detainee you
think working on such a short leash and
put a damper on the project but gamo at
home get bought play is surprisingly
revealing cornwall shows us the mess
halls putting greens and sleeping
quarters for the soldiers and sailors
spend their downtime she also got to
look at prisoners quarters but only a
few to convey the experience of daily
life without revealing the people who
live there she focused on the physical
spaces both groups inhabit
Cornwall photographed the compliant
detainee media room a single cell where
inmates with special privileges can
watch approved DVDs while shackled to an
overstuffed recliner the room featured a
two-way mirror so God's keep watch on
prisoners enjoying their leisure time
Cornwall hope to work props further
discussions about US military prisons a
former civil rights lawyer she now
advocates through photography Cornwall
feels the medium raises awareness of and
promotes discussions about issues most
people can't immediately relate to like
the debate over closing military prisons
like Guantanamo Bay